ف 15 يوما مرت على زلزال تركيا وسوريا
والهزات الارضيه الارتداديه ما زالت
مستمره بشكل دوري حتى الان لكن ربما تكون
هذه هي المشكله هل كان زلزالا واحدا وهل
يمكن اعتبار كل ما حدث مجرد توابع وهزات
ارضيه الثابت بحسب معهد المسح الجيولوجي
الامريكي ان ما حدث في السادس من فبراير
كان زلزالين مختلفي المركز والقوه الاول
في غازي عنتاب والثاني في قهرمان مرعش
وهذا ما ذهب اليه الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان حين اكد ان تركيا شهدت زلزالين
وانهما كانا بقوه القنابل الذريه
[موسيقى]
جميع علماء الزلازل اتفقوا على ان الزلزال
الاخير كان من اقوى الزلازل التي حدثت في
العالم وقدر قوته بقوه مئات القنابل
الذريه نحو 13 الف جريح يتماثلون للشفاء
في المستشفيات يعتبر حجم وشده الزلازل
ومدى تدميرها ظاهره طبيعيه
استثنائيه اتمنى الرحمه لكل القتلى الذين
يبلغ عددهم
35,418 من مواطني بلدي واتمنى شفاء
المصابين الذين تم انقاذهم الذين يبلغ
عددهم وخمسه الاف وخمسمائه وخمسه جرحى
وبالامس عاودت الارض التركيه الكره عدم
الاستقرار هذا ينذر ربما بكوارث اخرى
مقبله قد تكون تمهيدا لزلزال اكبر ما نشر
موجه من الرعب من الترقب خصوصا في تركيا
وسوريا فيوم امس المئات من السكان في
الدولهتين وايضا في لبنان افترشوا الساحات
العامه والشوارع خشيه سقوط المباني عليهم
مع تكرار الهزات الارضيه في تركيا دعت
اداره الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه المواطنين
وهي افاد دعتهم لتجنب دخول مساكنهم
المتضرره مع تواصل خطر الهزات الارتداديه
التي قد يتجاوز بعضها خمسه درجات على
مقياس ريختر لكن هل ما حدث في تركيا امر
شائع
الزلزالان الكبيران اللذان ضربا تركيا
وسوريا قبل اسبوعين كان شديدين وكان من
المتوقع ان تتبعهما هزات ارتداديه ربما
تمتد لايام او لاس
وحدث الزلزالان من مركزين ومن فوالق
زلزاليه مختلفه وبفارق تسع ساعات فصلت
بينهما اما زلزاله يوم امس فضرب الاول
محافظه هاتاي الاكثر تضررا من الزلزال
الكبير
واعقبه زلزال اخر بعد ثلاث دقائق ضرب
مدينه السويديه الساحليه بحسب اداره
الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه فماذا يحدث
عندما يضرب الزلزال وكيف ينتقل من مكان
لاخر ونركز هنا على تركيا وجوارها الزلازل
الماضيه حدثت في فالق شرق الاناضول وفي
صحف صفيحه الاناضول التي تحاذي الصفيحه
العربيه
وتتعامد على صدع البحر الميت
ولعدم اتصال الفوالق ببعضها بشكل مباشر
فعندما يحدث الزلزال يؤدي هذا لحدوث خلخله
في الفوالق المحيطه لينتقل الضغط من فالق
لاخر ما يقود لحركه غير اعتياديه للقشره
الارضيه هذا الضغط المتنقل من صفيحه ارضيه
الى اخرى يحدث العديد من الهزات
الارتداديه التي تستمر الى حين استقرار
الضغط بين الصفائح وتوقف حركه الفالق
ونتابع في الشرح بعد ان اثار الجدل
بتوقعاته في السادس من فبراير بتوقعاته
حول الزلزالين في السادس من فبراير عاد
العالم الهولندي فرانك هوجر ليثير الرعب
فبعد زلزاليل امس غرد ليلفت النظر نظر
متابعيه الى تغريده سابقه له توقع فيها
حدوث زلازل جديده في المنطقه بين العشرين
والثاني والعشرين من فبراير اي الان بل ان
الذروه قد تكون غدا بحسب توقعاته لكن
لم يعد بمفرده فكثير من علماء الزلازل
باتوا يتوقعون زلزالا هائلا قد يضرب
اسطنبول العاصمه الاقتصاديه لتركيا خلال
السنوات المقبله في فتره ربما لا تتجاوز
عام 2030
وجهه اخرى للزلازل تحدث عنها عالم الزلازل
التركيه ناجي جرور وقال ان الخشيه تسود من
ان تضرب زلازل اضنه وقبرص ودعا السلطات
تركيا الى عدم الاسراع في اعاده الاعمار
الا بعد فتره من الوقت بسبب استمرار توابع
الزلزال الصغيره والكبيره